Joshua I understand that you initially
made the act of killing to tell the
victims or the survivors story of the
Indonesian genocide but then things took
a turn you tell us what happened
yeah I began this project in
collaboration with a community of
survivors and every time we would film
together every time we would try and
talk about what happened in 1965 the
military would come and stop us I would
be arrested our crew would be arrested
our equipment would be taken we would be
detained and it was impossible really to
get anything done and at the same time
some of the survivors with whom I was
living in this canoe in this community
it was in a plantation about 60 miles
from the city of Madonna where I made
the act of killing they would send me on
these missions they would send us to go
film with a neighbor who they suspected
or knew was a perpetrator and thought
would know for example how a loved one
had been killed how one woman sent us to
try and find out how her son was killed
someone else how her aunt was killed and
we would go on these kind of missions on
behalf of the survivors to find out what
had happened and encountered these
perpetrators who within minutes of
meeting them would boast about how
they'd killed why they about how they'd
killed the details of how they killed
and sometimes we find out how people's
relatives had died and it was I realized
then this was this extraordinary
situation it was as though I'd walked
into Nazi Germany 40 years after the
Holocaust and the Nazis were still in
power the survivors too afraid to speak
not allowed to speak the perpetrators at
least unofficially encouraged to boast
about what they had done so that they
would be these kind of feared proxies of
the state and I am I felt I remember
feeling this situation is so important
so not extraordinary but important that
it demands that I give whatever it takes
and now it's about a decade on from I
and I've just finished this film there
was - we were there was this moment
where the
once we was clear we couldn't really
film with the survivors where we went
back we took a trip to Jakarta to meet
the Indonesian human rights community
which we hadn't met yet with the
survivors and we asked is this still too
sensitive this history is it too
dangerous to make this film everybody
said no you're onto something terribly
important we need a film for Indonesians
that exposes essentially what everybody
already knows but is it too afraid to
say so we need a film that comes like
the child and the emperor's new clothes
and says look the king is naked
everybody knew it that's too afraid to
say it but hopefully after it's exposed
by this movie people will be able to
talk about what happened and reassess
right look at what look at what happened
but also look at the nature of a regime
of impunity of corruption of fear that's
been built essentially on mass graves so
we talk okay how can we do this safely
and then one of the survivors said
continue to film the perpetrators
because they boast you've seen that and
in their boasting the audience will see
exactly why we're so afraid and the
nature of this regime so I started to
film every perpetrator I could find
across the region up the chain of
command to the city of Madonn where I
made the act of killing and beyond two
army generals retired living in Jakarta
and found that everybody I filmed was
open within minutes of meeting them they
would tell me these horrific stories of
how they killed and then right after
telling me how they killed often in
front of their grandchildren their wives
their children they would suggest that
they take me to the places where they
killed
I would accept those invitations and
then they would launch into these sort
of spontaneous demonstrations of how
they killed and complain afterwards that
they hadn't thought to bring props they
hadn't thought to bring machetes to use
as props or friends to play victims and
I was the questions in my head started
to shift from what happened historically
which I was quickly understanding to
what is happening now in wait that the
perpetrators want to be seen this way
why are they boasting about this for
whom are they boasting what's the
function of this boasting how do they
think I hear it how do they want their
society to see them how do they want the
whole world to see
and how ultimately do they see
themselves and really in pursuit of
answers to those questions I proposed
the following very openly to all of the
men I was filming look you've
participated in one of the biggest
killings in human history
your whole society is based on it your
lives are shaped by it you want to show
me what you've done I want to understand
what it means to you in your society so
show me what you've done in whatever way
you want I'll film the process I'll film
the reenactments and with that material
I'll try and answer these questions what
does it mean to you what does it mean to
your society how do you want to be seen
how do you see yourself and that's what
I did
Anwar the main character in the act of
killing was in fact the 41st perpetrator
I film then long before him I was long
before I met him I was proposing this
the method was not there for kind of
newer to get them to open up it was not
about giving them enough rope to hang
themselves indeed they had hung
themselves from the very first time I
filmed them it was a way of an it was a
response to their openness and effort to
try and understand why they're so open
and this the mood as I moved up the
chain of command until I met Anwar I
wasn't looking for the right main
character rather I was exploring the
nature of his impunity and the whole
journey I took with Anwar was the turned
out to be the core of that exploration
what did you see in Anwar that you
didn't see in the 40-some others I think
that on Mars pain is somehow close to
the surface and I think through the
reenacting it became through on Mars
boasting it became clear something that
I think was true of everybody else which
is that the boasting is not a symptom of
the lack of remorse the lack of a
conscience but in fact the opposite is a
desperate attempt to convince oneself
that what one did was right it's a
Dionne Juarez attempt to convince
himself that what he did was justified
you know one of there's another death
squad in the film named Adi and he says
in the film he says to Anwar killing is
the word and to me killing is the worst
thing you can do but if you're paid well
enough go ahead and do it but the key to
doing it successfully is to
make up an excuse so that you can live
with yourself afterwards and I think all
of the perpetrators they killed they
were handed an excuse by the government
justifying what they've done and they've
cloned to do your life for that excuse
and in Anwar perhaps because his pain is
so close to the surface he doesn't quite
believe the excuse and so he becomes
more and more strident in the
justification the justification spills
over into celebration
perhaps with armoir in that celebration
I thought I was catching the essence of
a regime of impunity which I think I was
and that's how the film has been has
worked in Indonesia unmasking this whole
regime but I think also I started to see
that the paradox at the heart of all of
this which is that what appears to be a
sign of the lack of remorse is the
opposite actually it's a sign of one of
the conscience of the killer and and
beyond that in that paradox lies a
tragedy about how we as human beings
what how there's a downward spiral of
corruption and evil and that once you've
killed once you've justified you get
away with it you justify it you even
celebrate it it's actually because you
know it was wrong at some deep level
that you're celebrating it that demands
that you commit further evil it demands
that you having thus corrupted yourself
in that way it demands that you suppress
your sort of the survivors so they don't
challenge your version of the events it
demands that you blame them and then you
can shake them down in markets or steal
their land which you hear about and see
in the film and it demands that you kill
again because if the army tells you now
now fill these people for the same
reason as you killed the first if you
refuse the second time it's tantamount
to admitting that it was wrong the first
time and that's what these men have been
desperately trying to run away from
so in essentially you see the act of
killing documents witnesses the downward
spiral of corruption and evil that all
human beings are capable of because we
have morality
once we corrupt ourselves with an
original sin get away with it and build
a normality on the basis of the terror
and lies that lie varying Joshua I
understand the act of killing is now
banned in Indonesia is that correct no
it's not bad actually we knew that if we
release the film in cinemas we would
have right after we made it we would
have to submit it to the censors in
Indonesia and we knew then that it was
likely to be banned particularly before
there was any support for the film in
Indonesia Indonesia still does ban films
and in particular they ban films dealing
with human rights violations and we knew
and so and we knew that if the films
banned then it becomes illegal to scream
if at all and that would be an excuse if
you like for the paramilitary group or
or the army to physically attack
screenings with impunity so to avoid
that situation so that the film could
come out in Indonesia all last autumn we
held screenings of the National Human
Rights Commission in Jakarta for indeed
Indonesia's leading news publishers news
editors news producers Indonesia's
leading filmmakers historians writers
educators some human rights advocates
survivors groups all of them really
loved the film and perhaps the most
extraordinary thing happened with the
news producers and news news publishers
if you're the editor of Indonesia's
largest news magazine for example you're
part of the establishment and you're
late you're in your late middle age and
you see in the act of killing men who
are perpetrator sort of the founding
fathers of this regime and you see them
at the end of the film totally destroyed
by what they've done either broken as in
the case of Anwar or in the case of Adi
the other death squad member in the film
totally hollow empty shells and you're
faced with a pretty stark choice do you
want to grow old like them as
perpetrators or do you want to take a
stance and news outlet after news outlet
decided they would break in reaction to
the film break their official silence on
the killing break their decades-long
silence on the
killings Indonesia's largest news
magazine produced a special double
edition of the magazine in which they
felt they should marshal fresh evidence
their own evidence to show that the act
of killing is a repeatable experiment it
documents something systemic
to the society they sent journalists all
over the country dozens of journalists
like 40 to see if they could find
killers elsewhere who would talk like
Anwar to their horror but not to their
astonishment they found that everywhere
they said journalists they were men like
Anwar who would boast and they collected
two in two weeks hundreds of pages of
boasting they edited it down to 75 pages
they produced another 25 pages about the
movie and came out with a double edition
of their magazine on the 1st of October
last year about the film the other news
outlets followed suit and Indonesia for
the first time has really started
talking about what happened in 65 the
film has come to Indonesia exactly like
the child in the Emperor's New Clothes
pointing at the king saying the king is
naked everybody had been afraid to say
it now it's been said so openly by the
perpetrators themselves that people
everyone else can start talking about it
without fear
so everyone who saw the film last autumn
we said look go back to your communities
show the film if it's by invitation we
probably don't have to show the film to
the censors they did so on the 10th of
December last year international human
rights day there were 50 screenings in
30 cities ranging in size from 30 people
as the smallest the smallest about 600
700 people with the largest that's grown
ever since on the 1st of April we passed
500 screenings in 95 cities and every
week there's more than the previous week
so the film is really fundamentally
opening this space where Indonesians can
both talk about what happened and
address the nature of the impunity and
the fear and the corruption and the
gangsterism that has been built on the
celebration of atrocity as something
heroic can you talk about turning on
camera and approaching the subject
without judgment you'd mention that you
spoke to these gentlemen with kindness
you know just there they're still human
beings they still respond to you know
people being nice but at some point you
had to show them it just who they are
and you approached it without judgment
how does the documentary and do that
when they have strong feelings about the
subject I think that you know I had a
screening for this film for prison
guards once in Denmark and it was really
interesting they put words to something
that I think we really as filmmakers
must do whenever we look at another
human being they said we always try to
separate the crime from the person and I
insist
I've never for a second suspended my
judgment of the crimes my I think my
moral point of view throughout the film
never Flags and throughout the
filmmaking never flagged but I insisted
to myself that I see these men as human
beings because I know the moment that I
condemned them as monsters or see Anwar
as a psychopath what I'm doing is
actually mainly reassuring myself that
I'm not like them and that if the film
has any core message it's that we are
all much closer to perpetrators than we
like to think indeed every article of
clothing touching my body now is haunted
by the suffering of the people who make
it for us and we know that all of them
without exception are working in places
like Indonesia that everything we buy is
produced in places like Indonesia where
there's been mass violence where
perpetrators of one and in their victory
they've built regimes of fear that keep
people to suppress the to get the human
cost of everything we buy incorporated
in the price tag that we pay we have
stories to justify these economists have
stories to justify this we I think know
it and we tell ourselves that the
trousers were wearing are Hugo Boss and
not the work of virtual slaves but the
work of a fashion designer so as to
forget the true nature of our reality I
think the film asks people to look at
the nature of reality and I knew that if
for a moment I see these men is anything
other than human I'm once again
escaping from the reality by telling
myself I'm not like them
so I insisted to myself I always comr
and his friends as human beings and I
and in order to deal with that and I
think that I feel I can't make a film
honestly about another human being
showing what we human beings are capable
of if I don't oh wait if I don't get
allow myself to get close to them and I
insisted that okay I would be close to
him and if for a moment I see him as a
monster or a psychopath I will stop I
will withdraw I'll take some days off to
rest I'll come back and approach him as
one human being to another now that was
difficult because when you become close
to someone when you become intimate with
someone of course you become vulnerable
to them and so hearing these awful
stories seeing these awful things then
gave me nightmares because I was open to
the fact that I would hope I would never
do these things but I'm very lucky never
to have to find out and so I would have
these nightmares then I would be afraid
of the nightmares that gave me insomnia
for four weeks four months and I think I
if I got through it it was because of
the support and the friendship and the
love of my Indonesian crew in particular
who was going through much the same
thing and who in a way I think together
we tried to light what was a very dark
journey for each other with our care
with our friendship with our last